the french interior ministry is planning
to boost its riot control arsenal
purchasing more weapons that fire rubber
bullets
that's despite a number of serious
injuries among the yellow vest
protesters caused by the non-lethal
ammunition
and numerous warnings from human rights
groups over their use
right well let's go live to our
correspondent in france dubinsky hi
again
quite an outcry over this what are the
dangers
well there are lots of dangers from
these lbd40s or more commonly known as
flashball weapons
now they're used to launch things such
as tear gas grenades
sound grenades and even these rubber
bullets
and those can all do significant damage
if they hit people in those protests
people with broken bones fractured teeth
bruising internal injuries we even saw a
number of
rt crew being injured over the last few
weeks
by some of the items that are being shot
out of those flash balls including the
rubber bullets
one of our colleagues was injured in the
face another injured in the leg
but the injuries can be even more
serious than that
and for some people they can be
life-changing
well why would the french government
want to
bolster its arsenal of these flash walls
they can
as they say launch things such as this
the rubber bullet
well that's largely due to the protests
that we've seen in france over the last
few weeks the country has been engulfed
by these violent protests with some
people
describing them as being the worst riots
in half a century
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
well the flash balls that the french
government
wants to look at purchasing as i say can
be used for tear gas sound grenades and
also those rubber bullets and they've
actually been some studies specifically
into the injuries caused as a result of
rubber bullets
with many civil liberty groups just
saying that they shouldn't be used
now a group of us academics published a
study in december of last year saying
that 15 percent of people
who were injured by rubber bullets
specifically actually
ended up with permanent injuries with
the majority of people
losing their sight they said three
percent of those injured
specifically by rubber bullets actually
went on to lose their lives
so the question is why is the french
government still
deciding to go with using the flash
balls which have been proven
in some cases to be deadly and still
wanting to spend
more than two million euros on its
version of protecting the state
okay charla dubensky in paris thanks
very much for that
you